>> So for both of you two, thanks for coming
by. So you guys have built a really cool application
[INDISTINCT] with technology. First, could
you introduce yourselves a bit, tell us a
bit about your organization, what you have
been building.
>> SOLIVEN: Sure. I'm Steve Soliven; I manage
a web team for Intercontinental Hotels Group.
And...
>> STUCKER: I'm Bob Stucker, I was part of
the newly rebranded ine.com website that we're
here that uses GWT.
>> Okay. Cool. So what did you guys build?
What did you do exactly in your product?
>> SOLIVEN: So most of the website is built
with GWT. Everything, but the header is all
AJAX and entire GWT application.
>> Okay. Okay, cool.
>> SOLIVEN: All the way from the home page
through confirmation.
>> So as you guys decided on which toolkit,
which technology to use to build your application,
how did you guys arrive to settling with GWT?
>> SOLIVEN: It really was on past experience
and the difficulty of dealing with JavaScript
and maintaining JavaScripts through other
websites that we have maintained. It just
became obvious that there needed to be a better
structure and better framework for JavaScript.
>> Okay. So some of the features that you
had used, GWT 1.5 for example, you know, it
was quite a few years [INDISTINCT] from 1.4
to 1.5 in Java. Today, in I/O, we talk a little
of which I/O features, there's a lot of cool
stuff coming there. What do you guys most
excited about in using in your own application?
>> SOLIVEN: You want that one?
>> STUCKER: Well, the biggest ones I think
for us is the run async, which is lazy loading
parts of our application, primarily because
at the moment our home page, performance wise,
we'd like to step it up a bit and we'd like
for us to be able to divide our applications
some more so that we can have that first load
be really fast and load the rest of our application,
you know, momentarily as the user is interacting
with the first page. So that's one of the
main things.
>> SOLIVEN: Yeah.
>> Okay.
>> SOLIVEN: That's my big one too. I've been
thinking about that one all day.
>> For an async?
>> SOLIVEN: Yeah.
>> Okay, cool. Well, there are other cool
things like client window, image window, I
don't know if you guys were to have one, but
image window [INDISTINCT] client, assuming
that, they have a lot more function than the
other stuff.
>> SOLIVEN: Right.
>> They got a lot of new stuff that they're
doing.
>> SOLIVEN: Yeah.
>> Cool.
>> SOLIVEN: I think we're really benefiting
from the fact that Wave was built using GWT.
So a lot of focus was put on performance,
and now we get to benefit from that.
>> Yeah.
>> SOLIVEN: Yeah.
>> STUCKER: That's a good endorsement for
our effort with the GWT, somewhere in that
direction.
>> Yeah. In fact, for a [INDISTINCT] feature
that's going to be in GWT 2.0 which is still
not released yet; it will be released in maybe
Q3 or later. But the [INDISTINCT], you can
already get that and Wave was built using
that.
>> SOLIVEN: We're going to do that as soon
as we get back.
>> Yup, cool. And, finally, for other developers
who are building some other types of applications,
some other types, would you recommend them
to use GWT or, you know, when would you say
that it's a good time to use it.
>> SOLIVEN: I would say if you're a Java development
shop, it definitely makes sense. You have
the right skill sets, the benefits you get
from using a Java IDE. Would you add anything
to that?
>> STUCKER: Yeah, I mean, GWT does provide
a new paradigm in terms of client-side application
development. So there's a certain learning
curve. And like Steve said, if you're, if
you're good with Java, then, you know, you're
good with GWT.
>> Right. All right guys, thanks for coming
by.
>> SOLIVEN: Thank you.
>> STUCKER: Thank you.